this time I would like to very much like
to welcome team cap first on out of the
gate Paul Rudd himself following come on
down here is right I just kind of want
to I don't want to step on Captain
America's toes nope all right sorry it's
all good now we're all set to go
all right the voice of Anthony Mackie
will be followed by his body
we love you Detroit it's not Detroit oh
that yeah so awkward I love it yeah
Sebastian Stan get out out here I did
not have hey don't have anything a city
for us it's captain self Chris Evans oh
all right I um this is fun couches I
thought it was gonna be like a table
right no it was a surprise to us
real [ __ ] on a table sorry very
comfortable we're keeping it real for
Elizabeth Olsen I'm gonna sit back
our director we have not yet heard from
Joe recite job crowded couch um uh Joe
alright welcoming back Kevin Feige
occupied front seat Chris I want to
throw you the first question here
because even though in the Marvel
Universe and in previous movies everyone
in the film is so well represented and
it's so balanced do you feel an even
bigger responsibility when you're a part
of a movie whose first two words of the
title is Captain America - I mean I
there's pressure but I don't think it's
anywhere near the pressure that to be
honest um people like the Russos or
marble feel because it honestly is the
movies live and die based on the
directors and the producers and how
we've all seen phenomenal actors and
great scripts that still didn't come to
fruition in a good way and it really
goes to show that a good movie lives and
dies based on the directors you could
have all the other pieces in place but
unless you have quality storytellers you
may fall on your face and so yeah
there's pressure but not as much as you
guys so lucky hey you know they did it
they did the job real well
Joe speaking to you as a director but
part of a team like that's a pretty rare
thing to see especially in a major
motion picture like two directors taking
on several movies do you feel that you
have particular strengths and Anthony
has different particular strengths hmm
that's a tough question if you put him
on the spot
no we've been doing this for a long time
together we grew up watching movies
together a very similar aesthetic and
working it we were working in TV for a
long time together I don't think that
there's a there is no true division of
labor for us it's um just a pure
collaboration and you know really you
know well we say that you know the the
only thing that is is is tricky for us
is is who has enough energy to get out
of the chair to go speak to the actors
after the take but other than that you
know everything is shared equally do
something technology was it any
considerations in the mill of the action
of bringing it to life you know I don't
want to repeat what my brother said on
the on the prior panel but you know
action is is very important to us these
movies are about action the characters
express themselves through action action
has to have storytelling to it for us or
it's vacuous and and superficial and you
know you can you'll get tired of an
action sequence if it's not either
defining the character or moving the
story forward in some way it takes an
incredible amount of effort and thank
God we have such an incredible team of
collaborators including Kevin and Markus
and McFeely and Nate Moore who who works
at Marvel as well who can who can work
with us and keep us honest in terms of
the storytelling and this cast who are
also the caretakers of the characters in
a way that we never could be so it you
know it's it's by far and away the
hardest thing to do on a film the
easiest thing to do on a film is when
you have a Soderbergh level of cast like
this to to put down the dramatic scenes
on camera especially with with
teachers of this caliber who have been
playing these parts for this long those
are some of the easiest things we do
some of the hardest things we do
is is the is executing the action and I
think the the toughest sequence by far
in this film which we literally probably
just finished a week or two ago was was
the airport sequence it's filled with a
lot of moving parts a lot of different
characters you want to move each
character forward you want to make sure
that you're not leaving anybody behind
and and you know I think we we went well
into the post process still reshaping
and rethinking and and reconfiguring
that sequence to make sure that it had
its maximum a storytelling thrust to it
food you fight against what I find in G
my men would fight yeah well I'd
probably want to aim low you know you
don't want to fight vision because he's
gonna just destroy ya I don't I think
you know it's in order to survive I'd
probably take Black Widow just because
Lee she's human you know but but out of
that away from a character standpoint
probably Iron Man cuz our characters
obviously have the most friction
features my question actually is for all
the actors I wanted to ask you about
doing that Airport sequence and and how
that was for you how many days it was
what was the most challenging part of
that and were you satisfied when you saw
the finished product yeah it was great I
mean it's hot it's Atlanta and in August
so I think everyone was was toasty and
there's only a couple scenes where you
know a couple shots where you know you
might have that one 50/50 where
everyone's running together but for the
most part it's you know picks and pops
and you're just getting pieces so it's a
lot of waiting around but you you really
have a confidence that this is going to
be something special you can see and
Anthony and Joe's face and Kevin these
guys gets so excited when these moments
work it's it's a meticulous process
because it's such a grand scheme so on
the day it's not as as you know cool and
romantic as you think it would be but
but there's an energy on set and an
excitement that that keeps you invested
knowing that it's going to be something
epic
Mark Hughes with Ford's Paul where do
you say I believe this belongs to you
Captain America was that improvised and
how many other different lines did you
try out several different ways of saying
that because I just seem so you and
Jeremy kill the messengers amazing I
love the film I just wanted to say thank
you and that's exactly how you sounded
deliver enough they did a better job
than I oh they're like I don't know I
think that was in the I think that was
always in the script the I think this
belongs to you we you know we sometimes
would play around with lines and stuff
while we're shooting it and these guys
would suggest things and but and then
sometimes we'd come up with the things
after the fact
one of the great things about having a
mask is that if you think of a great
joke afterward you have to you have to
match it to anything so you can add
stuff even in ADR but that was I think
that was one that was that was always in
there he's being modest Paul's like one
of the great improvisers that you could
hope to work with and it is true when
you have the masks and I think that was
a great benefit to us in the post
process again in terms of modulating the
tone in that that section of the movie
but you know we we had like endless
amounts of jokes that aunt and I and our
editor Jeff Ford and Kevin would sit in
the Edit room and laugh about for hours
and try to figure out it was not an easy
task which one was funnier than the
other and he you know he just gave us a
wealth of material
were you worked yeah how I felt as far
as being the fanboy the group that that
was not really there was very little
acting required in that scene for me you
know they've all worked together and
done this before I've just seen the
movies I mean I've seen all the Marvel
movies so to be there on the day I kind
of couldn't stop geeking out about it I
thought oh my god there's the shield
then and I thought you know there's that
there's that arm there you weren't
looking Wow there was a god damn man and
uh and so like that that kind of that
kind of hey even when I was getting the
suit on you know there's this area where
we get changed and stuff and that's like
well there's a Iron Man suit whoa you
know uh and there they all are
I did I did feel that that excitement of
what I can't believe that I landed here
this is nuts so it was really cool
question is for Emma Joe you got to
introduce a lot of the bug centric
superheroes the Maximus don't focus on
Ganon is Spider Man no wasp can you
explain this to what I'm not bringing
Evangeline Lilly to this film there were
drafts where wasp participated in the
splash panel fight the airport the
airport battle and the truth is it it
proves you took away the fun of seeing
her suit up for the first time of seeing
her on that road to being a hero we
experienced that with with with that man
in in his own movie we experienced that
with spider-man in many movies and we
have big plans and we later announced
the title of Paul's a sequel which is MN
and the wasp so we have very big plans
to unveil her in her own movie where she
can be the entirety the movie and not a
moment in inaction see
Kevin I a question for you because it's
kind of hard it isn't like an excited
fan to like live in the moment of the
movie because once you've seen it you're
like oh my god what's next right
and I was wondering as the marvel
universe expands like with some of the
Netflix shows being considerably darker
having a different tone do you feel that
ripple effects are going to be felt from
shows like that in the further cinematic
universe there might be but I think what
I love is is you're now seeing in the
film medium in the television medium the
reflection of what the comics have
always been there's always been that
great you know diversity of tone within
the comics and I love that that we're
seeing more more that on the bond on
various screens says that yes
that's a sure another interesting
evolution your character and he was
supposedly like protecting the true like
the all-american values in this case
he's just rejecting to come to the
government control and sharpey the
imagination so I would like you to talk
about that that's very interesting
sure well with regards to but whether
you know that was always a concern
whether you know the name America
whether or not that would kind of
polarize certain audiences but the truth
is the the name America I mean what he
stands for is something that's
ubiquitous across the world well you
know what he believes in you know honor
and morality and values that's something
you can find anywhere but in terms of
who he's been throughout the arc of his
character you know he's always kind of
fought for the greater good he's always
kind of put the needs of the masses
before his own desire and that's exactly
what's different in this film instead of
kind of whoops let that you know put
that in my lap for a second instead of
kind of dedicate dedicating himself
towards what others need in this film he
kind of prioritizes what he wants which
is a departure from what he's normally
Allegiant to so so I think it's it's
again it colors the character in a
really nice way you know you have a guy
who's this incredibly austere and moral
character it's hard trying to find ways
to make him layered and dynamic and I
think in this movie he becomes
potentially selfish where
he kind of puts his own desires first
but it's rooted in family which is I
think is a is a through-line that we can
all relate to
speaking of family Jeremy I wanted to
ask but as we got to know
Hawkeye more howdy
why do you feel that he joined caps I
immediately in this phone he's one who
called right Ryan Tug these guys they
wrote it no I think private times quite
boring you know you know and then you
know go help a friend it's not it's not
that and the moral compasses isn't it is
not far cry from from cap sort of
thinking as well anyway at least that's
how I see Hawkeye to be we're sort of
principled and he owes a debt to Scarlet
Witch so and her her brother so you know
when she's under duress it's a it's a
call to arms right yep
I'm an actor question actors always fill
in the gaps in the backstory in their
head
stop dickin towards the character that
isn't in the script and that we never
see what is all y'all can answer this
what is something that you know about
your character that we don't know I
think that's like I'll never tell kind
of a boundary hey John you yeah people I
don't know it's a good question yeah I
kind of go on board with you that I
think to some degree I mean this is
almost like the way it is being an actor
in general some things you know certain
things you want to share and certain
things you don't I think some degree
it's almost nice having certain parts of
the character that are intimate and
ultimately at the end of the day these
guys do a good job of fleshing out the
tones that they want you to see better
than we ever could that's it's one of
the things when I was just doing the
interview with you guys you too in Kevin
and the Russos and they were just
talking about how they form these
stories and form these arcs and you
really think these things I'm kind of
deviating from the question but it just
feels worthy to bring up because it blew
my mind I've known these for a long time
now and we were having a interview and
they were talking about how they were
going to a meeting and
sometimes you think with these movies
these giant Marvel movies any big movie
where you think there's a thousand cooks
in the kitchen you assume there's some
sort of formula some algorithm that
kicks in and there's a thirty people in
suits being like this is what it needs
to be but the truth is it really is Joe
and Anthony and Kevin and Nate in a room
mapping out stories for so many
characters so many arcs and they're
making them real they're making them
actual fleshed out arcs and conflicts
that are worthy of a film it's all the
explosions in the world aren't going to
make you care and and it's it's nuts to
think that it really comes from a few
people's brains and again this this is
not exactly the answer to the question
but I think it was worth bringing up
because it blew my mind because I've
been doing this for a while and it was
nuts to kind of realize it really does
start from just a few people what was
what was your process like in this film
as opposed to Winter Soldier when he's
not himself he's not be captain well
just to piggyback on what Chris said you
know I think I'm always fascinated about
the same thing it's just you know for
example our writers Christopher Stephen
and it's just phenomenal to me the way
that they were able to write a script
that gave every character a moment and
arch you know an arc and and
particularly I think they were the ones
that kind of figured it to the
temperature of Bucky Barnes you know how
much of the guide is is back from the
first movie how much of the winter
soldiers there and for me it was just
sort of taking it off the page and
following them you know but a lot of
that I think is determined in the in the
writing and then also in the decision
that these guys make you know in the fun
part for me is I never know you know
where they're going to take it so key
movie pilot calm have a question for
Elizabeth mm-hmm
so in each of Ultron you role like
scared of your powers and then in Civil
War you started meeting some
Vin's people still could not really
control and you're still terrified of
your powers do you think Scarlet Witch
will ever be able to have any confidence
with like real confidence with her
powers or anything this is the peak of
her confidence level I mean I I think
what ends up happening was that she was
starting to feel confident but it was
more it wasn't about her powers is more
about they the conflict she had with
making a big mistake but I think what's
interesting is every superhero has a
weakness and I've always thought of hers
as she's the person who gets in her way
that she's kind of limit limitless and
so that's to me an interesting character
trait I don't know what we're going to
do next but I'm I think of her as being
like an incredibly strong powerful
person and I and it's also fun because I
feel like she she could flip by the way
because of her her mind I think she I
think there are a lot of things that
could possibly be played with but I'm
not in control of that but I think this
film was a lot about just conflict in
general of what's right how to use your
abilities or whether you should or not I
think that's that was consistent theme
throughout the whole film so I think
it's just consistent that as opposed to
her being not confident she is on a
growth arc and it is it is part of her
development it's very tricky with very
powerful characters because unless they
have an internal struggle or a flaw that
limits them then they do become
limitless and then the storytelling
becomes muddled and and and not very
interesting yeah you know she could have
stopped that fight at the airport and in
five seconds if she were at the peak of
her powers so it really you know really
has to do with you know her character
specifically going on a journey to
understand what the limits of her power
her powers are she makes a mistake very
early in the movie that sets her back
and and you know we'll get to see where
she goes infinity war
simply you have a pleasant problem it's
like I think after this film everybody
had such a high point um everybody can
carry their own solo film people are
going to be clamoring for a Captain
America for and maybe a war machine
movie and that'd be a good idea and how
do you deal with that pleasant great hey
listen that that's that's listen marvels
and I'm you know I've been really
talking a lot about this impressed but
it really is over the course of the you
know I've been doing this for a while
now and it really is nice to kind of
step back in the first couple years of
your involvement of the franchise your
very internal you're scared about being
the thing that's going to cause it
you're going to be awful and you're very
terrified in a very egoic manner but as
you kind of continue on the journey you
kind of realize how amazing it is what
they're doing and what they're
accomplishing and how fortunate you are
to be a part of it this unbelievable
inter webbing of stories and you kind of
are just so fortunate to be a part of it
and I say keep going let's keep going
let's let the way it gets bigger and
bigger because it's not stopping it's
not like they're making bad movies to
make great movies and you want to if you
want to keep putting in this superhero
box you can but the fact is it's still
good movies it's good movies that they
especially the Russos they ground them
in such an authentic way it's real
humans real struggles real conflict good
cinematic storytelling with like a
streak of superhero flavor in it so I
say keep it going like if you can keep
doing it keep doing
you